[Music]
hey guys how was the party it was really
fun
Asus he's wearing the woman's sweater
and he's drunk
well he didn't drive drunk and he's home
before curfew so that's what I thought
we know my name's Simon the most part my
life is totally normal
I have a family that I actually like and
there's my friends we do everything
friends do we drink way too much dice
coffee walking on carbs so I'm just like
you except I have one huge ass secret
hey I like boots I said I like your
boots
bye nobody knows I'm gay have you seen
the new post about the closeted gay kid
at school
what who do you think it is
can I call you back you're blue I'm just
like you this was in this stage it's
nice to know there's another guy at
school with the same secret when did you
first realize it was a bunch of little
things like my first girlfriend I think
I'm fine with you
Wow thank you grab back wasn't my
proudest moment sometimes I think I'm
destined to care so much about one
person it nearly kills me me too
I'm done living in a world where I don't
get to be Who I am
I deserve a great love story and I want
someone to share with
[Music]
look so
these last few years it's almost like I
can feel you holding your breath I'm
supposed to be the one that decides when
and where and who knows that's supposed
to be my thing
his claim this is about to get balamb
takus Africa
you're not in a happy are you she's cute
but she's just not really my type not
because she's black I love black women
not like you know I have a thing for
black women I just I just I just love
all women
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you